I don't know what it is about Wiltshire
but this is the second week in a row
I've come here to film an episode of
swipe featuring men who can fly last
week it was all about a wingsuit this
week a jet-powered one
this video of British inventor Richard
browning testing his jet-powered suit
has been watched more than a million
times the ex city trader and former
Royal Marine reservist has no formal
engineering training but he does have a
huge amount of curiosity as I discovered
when visiting him at home in Wiltshire
yes so this is the lab this is where
I've spent quite a bit of time over the
last 18 months developing the the jet
suit is this the very suit that you wear
that is yeah we suspend it all in that
place just so you can connect it up and
test it but yeah that is that is pretty
much all the equipment you you have a
pair of engines on each arm so that's
one arm there's the other arm and these
ones actually go around my where my
waist at the back each engine then is
plugged into into one of these brains
and then we got up here this is a
holographic heads-up display helmet from
the company called daiquiri it's a
pretty neat piece of kit it displays all
the engine data and fuel consumption
data that gets wirelessly transmitted by
the suit so it's it's a very neat way of
being able to monitor the system and
monitor our fuel so it's giving you
information on the inside of the visor
yeah it's kind of hovering in a like a
fighter pilot kind of heads-up display
if you'd like to have a look and see
what I see when I'm flying it this is
heavy how much would this cost daiquiri
sell these now for about $15,000 this is
the only black one in existence they're
very kindly built sir a really quite
customized one okay I think I think
maybe it's a bit big for me the suit
cost Richard less than a hundred
thousand pounds to create but the
hundreds and hundreds of man-hours from
him and his team he says have been the
greatest expense and if you're wondering
why he even began the project if I'm
really honest it was the starting point
was just have an enormous amount of fun
taking on the challenge of human flight
but from a very different perspective
taking it on from the idea of leveraging
the human mind and body and then adding
to that rather than putting the human
form in a flight vehicle you know what
would what would be possible if you
really leveraged the mind and body
capability so time to find out more
about Richards mind and body
capabilities
we're heading to a nearby farm his
testing ground a few minutes away
it's suiting up time and there's a lot
to consider oh I forgot one of those GSM
things again never mind it all work
perfectly Deb can I have your help for a
second Richard's wife seems to be used
to this part of the operation helping
him buckle up and get ready does this
not worry you it did initially when he
first told me about the project and what
was aiming to do and but since I've been
following it for asking monks I
understand how it works a bit more it is
not as bad as it looks and I might even
possibly have another go myself with the
arm engines at some point that's a
fireproof suit you're wearing yeah yes
it is there's a there's a fireproof base
layer underneath all of this that's just
really a precaution even though the fuel
is usually diesel paraffin or jet fuel
it's really not particularly dangerous
it doesn't turn into a vapor cloud it
doesn't suddenly spontaneously ignite
it's all very much sealed up in the fuel
tank system warming up the engines takes
about 90 seconds and it's noisy
you can smell the fuel and feel the
intense heat here we go
richard says the suit could fly
thousands of feet high and at speeds of
several hundred miles per hour the only
thing stopping him from doing that is
the danger risk he controls the
direction of the suit by adjusting where
he points the engines it's a very
strange feeling a bit like riding a bike
in three dimensions you don't really
think about what you're doing when
you're riding a bike it just happens the
balance is quite natural Richards team
is now working on a second
more advanced version of the suit and
even a children's option that apparently
won't involve jet engines but still aims
to give wearers a superhero feel